It's really, really awesome going to the Olympic Trials,...
...not only representing Harvard but also with my teammates, just because...
...it's really nice to be able to wear that "H."
Reaching for the Olympics is definitely my riskiest goal so far.
I kind of came to the realization like, "Whoa, I'm on the road to Rio."
"I'm actually trying to do this."
Taking a step back and kind of looking at what I've been doing,...
...how far I've come, it's happening really fast but it's a lot of fun...
...and that's what I like about it, discovering new things about myself.
We have a pretty competitive US team,...
...so just to be able to even compete for a spot on that...
...is such a privilege and an honor.
To be able to represent the US at the Olympics would be really special.
It would be amazing to wear your country on your chest...
...and represent your country.